say hello Mona Johnny they're doin
ba-ba-ba-ba
why were Genji TM what is the world what
Tina Jang Dongmin whether the eyewear
with a jump a for you may well be like
what Ronnie Nene hey Jonica
yeah Giada yeah you mean watching Lee
tinglin et Annika
hey yo Joe the yam pourquoi Jagger oh
you that roll Mayo Mayo Jean Daniel H
anima namaha no ma no cally I mean Ali
now I'm going to Dow was assaulted you
sure a publisher would use a tumor she
could beat our nitrogen Tasha was a
shortage cut em would you the UFO be
charged and done three no three got a 20
- where - dolphin Dorian told her way
she shootin well put on eBay at yo some
cow comment you does not beautiful
tomatoes for Thomas single yes we know
just because on patient a 20-ish life is
he another that oriental Poochyena
- well not now but to ensure shakiness
dnt issues identity Palazzo Capponi yo
TK y se yes it is equally in fact work
on booty no sure
nah just Rica either here would ya since
I wore too much from the parsley butter
so I tap on the drummer I mean bellezza
did me up what you're done you show the
haha
Archie Sean yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but so take action get what he
said your social certainly nature
John what about so hey what am I see on
the news for the day to what they got
room for the goats are Beto Beto agenda
hi Lydia - mwah - Jagger's away
sure Peter Rooney she she you may touch
Peter your seat on Sunday Kshama oh you
sham the mega Donna Jo Jo Jo B $20
million Toman el Nisha elegiggle zona
Nikki
Chavo Donna cancer machine de fukatsu
need your beater create your title
attach a Mesa so you will
enjoy a good soak Willa which other to
ensure your harsher high order Goguen
Fabio Jen Don and tell you to go finding
Wendy what's a district is she 120 are
you actually a high pot yeah why you in
no jingyan way you're jingling let me
shoot up the other yeah I'm down to
enjoy each other I kill cutting cohere
what
so you made you're dead on scene is on
the jungle turn your Hedorah give me
tomatoes [ __ ] tinium so you tell me
really all share the assertions on the
table you're not Archer come in Joe Joe
Joe hiya
so you won't need a guitar need a guy
shanem oh yeah come on Satan when did
you get so well on my own it I fire you
what should be idea number number phone
foe Tasha what you don't need to cry in
our chaeyoung Hamdani for the face on
the syria page on the ha ha ha yeah
right magenta gene DNA catch on cheetah
jaga todo en de jaga - ha woman the
center Jojo Jojo ah ah ah
well was a finisher and and to my don't
worry you should gather yes winner is do
pony what would would you a single
Cherie good beat out to me ah 24 3 work
gonca sure what we were on board we
Sonya raha you [ __ ] the talent here
and that walk which idea oh ok Luka
well can we finish off in English here
and there gotta run I gotta go see my
grandson play hockey so I'm running a
little bit late here so we cut the last
languages a little bit short but it's
been a great experience it's been a lot
of fun of course we're going to disagree
in a few items but I think the main
thing is you'll agree is if people are
enthusiastic about languages if they're
motivated if they put in the time if
they pay a little bit attention to
what's going on like you were saying
about the tones
concentrate I mean it's a lot easier
than people think I agree 100% once
again and I mean yeah I did will say oh
you had a talent for languages well yeah
sure if I've done five or six languages
I mean yeah I'm better at it than you
are because you haven't done any so I
mean yeah if I play five instruments I'm
going to learn a sixth in
you know mark I learned the cello faster
than you if you can't play the piano but
but in terms of innate you know genetic
talent I'm not convinced that it's there
I think it's a matter of of what we're
interested in we get some initial
success some initial experience and it
just motivates us to learn more and
chances in life if you have a great
chance like to have a French girlfriend
or a lot of friends if you want dances
your language learning that's what I
think
absolutely listen look I really
appreciate this I've got a bunch of
recordings here we'll see how we put
them up but I'd much appreciate it right
ok thank you bye-bye take care